("The Four Seasons" by Antonio Vivaldi)
- Crayon.
- Crayen.
- Crayen?
- Mmm, did she say crayen?
- Crayen.
- Crayon!
- Crayon.
- No! You're wrong.
- You know!
- It's one syllable.
- We had a huge debate
about this in college.
- But the O.
- Kenny is confusing
college and kindergarten
'cause he says crayen.
- Carmel.
- Caramel.
I don't know if I'm--
- I was expecting that.
- Carmel.
- Caramel.
- Wait, did you say carmel?
- No, I say caramel.
- Caramel?
- See, but I sometimes say carmel
and sometimes I say
caramel, it really depends.
- Really, I never say caramel.
- It's like caramel, it's too fancy.
Who am I, some highfalutin
kinda character?
- Jewelry.
- Yeah, jewelry.
- Some people say je-wel-ry.
Those are overachievers.
- Jewellery.
- No.
- No one says je-wel-ry. (laughs)
- Jewellery.
- Je-wel-ry.
- See, this is another,
you gotta take the time
to enjoy the syllables in the words.
- If you try to rob someone and were like,
"Give me your je-wel-ry!"
I would just laugh.
- Hero.
- Eero.
(woman laughs)
- Jairo.
- Hero.
- Hero?
- Wow, I would say jairo.
- Eero, which is the way
Greek people say it, I think.
- It could be giro, it could be gairo.
- Gairo.
(man laughs)
- Who says gairo?
- I've never heard that one.
- Jairo's so wrong.
- It makes me feel dirty when I say
jairo.
- Jairo!
- It's a Greek word, so I'm
gonna just give us points
for knowing anything about it.
(both laugh)
- Nobody should speak,
is what we've learned.
This is why texting is the new evolution
of language.
- Mm-hmm.
- I feel like you can't apply
logic to the English language.
(laughs)